[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن حديث الساعه الان تحليقه
من طاب صيني في سماء ولايه مونتانيا قال
الامريكيون انه لاغراض التجسس بما تنفي
بجن ذلك وتعبر عن اسفها
هذه الصور من العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف بعد
ساعات من قمه اوكرانيه اوروبيه وفضلا عن
التضامن مع اوكرانيا في حربها حرب روسيا
عليها بحثت القمه ايضا طلب كياب الانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي
اما هذه الصور فتاتينا من جباء عاصمه
جمهوريه جنوب السودان المناسبه زياره
البابا فرنسيس التي الذي كانت له عام 2019
محاوله للمصالحه بين رئيس سيرفكان ونائبه
رياكشار لم تكلل وقتها بالنجاح
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
منعطف جديد للتوتر بين واشنطن وبيجين بعد
اختراق منطاد صيني لاجواء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واشنطن تتحدث عن انشطه
تجسسيه بلنكن يلغي زيارته ويقول لنظيره
الصيني ان الخطوه انتهاك للسياده وبجيد
تقول ان المنطاد مدني ظل طريقه وتنفي
نيه التجسس
من كيف كبار مسؤوليه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجددون دعمهم لعضويه اوكرانيا
يطالبهم بالاسراع في مفاوضات الانضمام
لتبدا هذا العام ويؤكد حاجه بلاده الماسه
لاسلحه بعيده المدى واشنطن تعلن عن حزبتي
مساعدات عسكريه وتجيز اول عمليه نقل لاصول
روسيه مصادره لاستخدامها في دعم اوكرانيا
في ختام اجتماعه الطائر الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل يهاجم سياسات الرئيس السعيد ويقول
انها تحرض على الاقتتال وتغطي على فشل
الانتخابات ويعلن عن سلسله تحركات بدءا من
الاسبوع المقبل ردا على اعتقال احد
قياديين وسعيد يقول ان القانون يسري على
الجميع وانه لابد من المحاسبه وتطهير
البلاد
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم سياقه الاجتماع
الطارئ للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل والذي
بحث سبل الرد على ما اعتبره استهدافا للحق
النقابي بعد يومين من اعتقال السلطات
مسؤولا نقابيا وفي الوقت الذي شدد فيه
الرئيس قيس سعيد على ان الحق النقابي لا
يمكن ان يتحول الى غطاء لمقارب سياسيه لم
تعد تخفى على احد وفق تعبيره اتهمه الامين
العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبي بدعوه
الشعب للاقتتال قائلا ان تصريحاته محاوله
لصرف الانظار عن النتائج الهزيله
للانتخابات وفشل الخيارات الاقتصاديه وفق
تعبيره والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم الى اين تسير العلاقه بين الرئيس
السعيد واتحاد الشغل كيف جاءت الاجابات
جاءت على النحو التالي
46% قالوا انها تتجه نحو القطيعه
في مقاله 26% انما تعرفه ومجرد توتر مؤقت
بينما قال
28% انه لا تغيير في العلاقه بين الجانبين
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم كالعاده دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
غداه لقاء البرهان بوزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي قوى سياسيه ومدنيه سودانيه
ترفض التطبيع مع اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
فصل جديد من التوتر بين واشنطن وبيجيل
فجره تحليق منطاد صيني في اجواء ولايه
مونتانا الامريكيه وبشبهه التجسس اخذت
الازمه وتيره متسارعه جعلت رئيس
الدبلوماسيه الامريكي يؤجل زياره الى
العاصمه الروسيه رغم نفي الصين عفوا الى
العاصمه الصينيه رغم نفي الصين ان يكون
منطادها للتجسس
منطاد في سماء ملبده بغيوم ازمه متراكمه
بين واشنطن تحلقه في اجواء ولايه مونتانا
الامريكيه اضاف اضطرابا اخر الى علاقات
بلدين ليست في افضل ايامها توجد في
مونتانا قواعد جويه ومخازن وصواريخ
استراتيجيه قضيه من طرد التجسس دفعت وزير
الخارجيه الاميركي
الى تاجيل زياره لبيج كانت مقرره الاثنين
المقبل علق مسؤول امريكي بالقول ان واشنطن
واثقه من استمرار الحوار مع بيجين رغم
ارجاء الزياره مضيفا ان تحديدا موعد جديد
لها سيكون بعد توفر الظروف الملائمه على
حد قوله كبار المسؤولين نصحوا الرئيس جو
بايدن باستبعاد خيار اسقاط المنطاد بسبب
مخاطر حطامه فحجمه يعادل ثلاث حافلات وفق
بعض التقديرات وقبل قرار عدم الاسقاط جهزت
مقاتلات بعضها من طراز اف 22 في ولايه
مونتانا كان متحدث باسم البنتاجون اوضح ان
المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا عسكريا او جسديا
لمن هم على الارض عن بعد عقد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
اجتماعا مع كبار المسؤولين في البانتاجون
كان اوستن في مانيلا التي بحث فيها مع
المسؤولين الفلبينيين تهديدات الصين في
المنطقه ونشاطاتها المثيره للجدل في بحر
جنوب الصين علقت بيجين على القضيه بعده
تصريحات
تطورت صيغها مع تطور التداعيات اذ اعلنت
الحكومه الصينيه ان المنطاد مجرد اداه
مدنيه للبحث العلمي ودخوله المجال الجوي
للولايات المتحده تم عن غير قصد وبسبب قوه
قاهره وقبل ذلك نفات المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه ان تكون لبلادها نيه
لانتهاك اراضي اي دوله او الجوي داعيه
لجانبين الى العمل معا بهدوء وحذر بحذر
تراقب كندا ايضا تحركات من اخر في اجوائها
دون ذكر اسم الصين في اوجه تحذيرات
امريكيه بان الصين هي اكبر تحد امني
تواجهه حاليا يخفض علو منطاد فرص عدم
تاجيج الوضع المتاسم قائمه الخلافات
الطويله ومتشعبه منها تايوان وبحر جند
بالصين وحلفوشي
غير المرغوب فيه ما يفرق بين وعشره وبيجين
هذه الايام كثيرا وعابر للقارات
وقد اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الوزير انطوني بلينكن اجرت اتصالا هاتفيا
مع نظيره السنين لابلاغه بعدم سفره الى
بيجين في ضوء وجود منطاد تجسس صيني فوق
الاجواء الامريكيه واكدت الخارجيه
الامريكيه في بيان لها ان بلنكن اوضح
لنظيره الصيني انه لن يكون من المناسب
زياره بيجين في الوقت الحالي في ظل هذه
القضيه معتبرا وجوده في الاجواء الامريكيه
اي المنطاد عملا غير مسؤول وانتهاكا واضحا
لسياده الولايات المتحده والقانون الدولي
واضاف بيانه الخارجيه الامريكيه انا اكد
للنظيره الصيني ان بلاده ملتزمه
بالدبلوماسيه والحفاظ على خطوط اتصال
مفتوحا كما اكد كذلك انه سيكون على
استعداد لزياره الصين بمجرد ان تسمح
الظروف بذلك
وفي الرد الامريكيه ايضا قال المتحدث باسم
ان كل الاحتمالات المتعلقه بامكانات
استخدام المنطاد الصيني ما زالت قيد
الدراسه واضاف المتحدث باسم البنتاجون ان
المنطقه الصيني يحلق في الاجواء الامريكيه
وان الوزاره تدرس خيارات التعامل معه في
ضوء ما قد يشكله من تهديد المنطاد الذي
تقول الولايات المتحده انه صيني ورصدته
فوق اراضيها انطلق وفق مسؤولا في وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه من الصين ووصل الى جزر
الوشيان في الاسكا ومن ثم واصل المنطاد
ومساره عبر غربي كندا خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه قبل ان يصل الى محطته الحاليه في
مكان ما فوق ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه حيث
رصد وتوجد في شمال غرب الولايات المتحده
قواعد جويه حساسه وصواريخ استراتيجيه تعمل
مثل مثل هذه المناطيد على ارتفاعا يتراوح
بين 24000 متر وسته وثلاثين الف متر وهو
اعلى بكثير من الطائرات الملكيه المدنيه
التي بامكانها التحليق على ارتفاع يقارب
اربعه عشر الف متر فقط
انضموا الينا الان من بيجين الاعلاميه
والباحث السياسي ومن واشنطن
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون اسيا نبدا بضيفنا من بيجين سيد هوان
لماذا لا تبدو التبريرات الصينيه مقنعه
للامريكيين
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اولا
اعتقد هناك التكبير لهذا الامر بسبب
هناك بعد المسؤولين الامريكيين تريدون
الفرد ايضا الضغوط على الصين يعني
هذه الحادثه
ويعني
[موسيقى]
تريد ايضا تقديم التنازلات
فيما يتعلق في مفاوضاتها مع الولايات
المتحده حوارها مع الولايات المتحده ولكن
لماذا تراها مضخمه في حين ان المساله ليست
ليست بسيطه ان ياتي منطاد فوق الاجواء
الامريكيه وبهذه الاهميه
لان هذا
المنتاج يعني كما وصف الجانب الامريكي انه
لا يشكل خطرا على امن الولايات المتحده
وهي مجرد
للاغارات الارسال الجويه والمدنيه وكذلك
هذه هذا المنطال لا يمكن الجمع المعلومات
التجسس لان هذه وسيله وسيله بدائيه جدا
ويعني هو فقط بسبب
[موسيقى]
انحرفت ان يعني بسبب الرياح
عرفات المصارح المخطط ودخل الى
الامريكيه وقد اعرب السنجار الاسد في ذلك
فصين تاملوا من الولايات المتحده يعني
التعامل
بالهدوء وحذر يعني منفتح يعني
مواصله تواصل اتصال مع الجانب العربي
امريكي لمعالجه احد الامر بشكل مناسب
في المقابل الولايات المتحده وهنا نسال
السيد ديفيد سيدني في واشنطن الولايات
المتحده تؤكد على ان المساله مساله تجسس
كيف يمكن التاكد من ذلك
بين الجيش
والاستخبارات لديهم موقف اصدروا اطلقوا
المنطاد وربما هنالك وزاره الخارجيه هم
الاقل نفودا ويشعرون بالرضا تجاه ما حصل
لكنه ليس بيديهم حيله اعتقد انه كانت حركه
حكيمه من الوزير لعدم زيارتي لان هذا
الامر سيصعب الموضوع انا امل ان يجد
البلدان طريقه للتعامل مع هذا الامر من
اجل تقليل التوتر وقد كان هناك الكثير من
نقاط الاختلاف في سابقا ايضا سيد سيدنا
ضيفنا من بجين اشار الى ان قضيه المنطاد
المنطاد مساله بدائيه في جمع المعلومات
والتجسس هل تعتقد فعلا بان الصين يمكن ان
تقدم على طريقه بدائيه كهذه اذا اخذنا
بمفرده بدائيه
هذه هذا ليس من طادا بدائيا هو منطاد بالغ
التعقيد تستخدم الصين مثل هذه المناطيد في
السابق في هواي وفي المحيط الهادئ اذا بعض
الصور الموجوده نرى هنالك استشعار
استشعارات اجهزه استشعار حساسه لهذا
المنطاد بالتالي هو ليس بدائيا وبالتالي
فان عمليه التجسس بالمنطقه هي عمليات عملت
عليها الصين لعقد من الزمن لسوء الحظ ان
وصف بدائي الامر فقط ليس صحيحا الغاز
زياره بلانكن السيد رونج هوان في بيجين
حدثت ليس بالهين هل يمكن فعلا ان تجازف
بجين بعلاقاتها مع الولايات المتحده بهذا
الشكل بسبب هذه القضيه
اعتقد ان الصين يعني منفتح على
الاجراء والحوار مع الولايات المتحده
كما نعلم ان هذه الزياره
للمرتقبه لوزير خارجيه الامريكي كان جاءت
ايضا طلب من الجنب امريكي
ولذلك
القرار
ويد الولايات المتحده ولكن تريد ان
تحافظ على قنوات التواصل مع الجانب
الامريكي وتريد ايضا ان التعايش السلمي مع
الجانب الامريكي
يعني ايجاد
حقيقه التعاون وفوز المشتركه رقم وجودها
الخلافات شكرا لك
شكرا لك ايضا ديفي من واشنطن
قليل المتحدي باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ستيفاندو جاريك ان المنظمه
الدوليه تشعر بالقلق كلما كانت هناك
توترات متصاعده بين الصين والولايات
المتحده وقلد شريك انه سيتعين على واشنطن
وبجين التعامل مع حادثه المنطاد وبذل ما
في وسعهما لخفض التوتر
كقاعده عامه نشعر بالقلق كلما كان هناك
توتر متصاعد بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين وقد اشار الامير العام
الى ذلك في كثير من الاحيان لكن سيتعين
على البلدين التعامل مع هذه الحادثه
بالذات وبالنظر الى المكانه القياديه
العالميه لكلا البلدين اعتقد انه يتعين
عليهما القيام بكل ما في وسعهما لخفض
التوتر
في فتره فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا عوده
لملف التجسس بين الولايات المتحده والصين
وسنسال عن طبيعته ومراحله وتاثيراته على
العلاقات الثنائيه
[موسيقى]
على صدى سفارات الانذار فياب اجتمع قاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع القاده الاوكرانيين
هناك من جهه تعبير اوروبي عن دعم اوكرانيا
في حرب روسيا عليها ومن جهه ثانيه بحث
الجانبان في هذه القمه غير المسبوقه وذات
الدلاله الرمزيه طلب اوكرانيا الانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي قد تقوم في وجه ذلك
المسعى عقبات عده وقبل الحسم جاء قرار اخر
من وراء المحيط بتقديم واشنطن حزمه
مساعدات جديده لقيام تتجاوز قيمتها ملياري
دولار
بكثير من الدعم عقد الاجتماع الاوكراني
الاوروبي في كييف دعم عسكري وسياسي
واقتصادي وانساني تعور عليه اوكرانيا
لمواجهه روسيا على بعد ايام من دخول الحرب
عامها الثاني مطار بتسريع مفاوضات
الانضمام الى الاتحاد وتزويد كييف بسلاح
بعيد المدى
اذا وصلني السلاح بشكل مستعجل والصواريخ
بعيده المدى فلن نبعدهم عن باخموت فحسب بل
سنبدا في نهايه
اوكرانيا تعرف الاحتياجات الخاصه بذلك نحن
ممتنون لجميع الدول التي تسير على هذا
الطريق بجانبنا
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تتحدث عن عقوبات
اضافيه على روسيا وعن ضروره دفعها 8 ما
تفعله حربها في اوكرانيا
ناقشنا خلال هذه القمه الطريقه المثلى
لجعل روسيا تدفع ثمن التدمير الهائل الذي
احدثته في اوكرانيا نحن نستعرض مع شركائنا
الخيارات المتاحه لتحقيق ذلك الجاني يجب
ان يدفع الثمن وان يخضع للمساءله ويرى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان اوكرانيا في طريقها
اليه
ان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومستقبل الاتحاد هو اوكرانيا وقدركم هو
قدرنا نقول ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيدعم
اوكرانيا في كافه مراحل انضمامها للاتحاد
الاوروبي ولسنا خائفين من روسيا والكرم
لان تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه ان هذا
اللقاء يكتسي اهميه بالغه وتعلق عليه
امالا كبيره لزياده الدعم العسكري
الاوروبي لاوكرانيا لاسيما مع احتدام
المعارك شرقا وجنوبا وفي ضوء تقارير تتحدث
عن استعداد روسيا لشن هجوم على اوكرانيا
بالتزامن مع الذكرى الاولى للحرب
فبينما كان لقاء منعقدا كانت سفارات
الانذار تدوي في العاصمه وبقيت المعارك
العنيفه مستمره في الجنوب في انتظار
الاسلحه النوعيه والثقيله التي تقول كياف
ان من شانها وحدها قلب المعادله
حول استمرار الدعم المالي لاوكرانيا
بحزمات المساعده التي اعلن عنها الاتحاد
الاوروبي اضافه للدعم العسكري الذي تقدمه
الدول الاوروبيه تعتبر امرا شديد الاهميه
لاوكرانيا في فتره الحرب وستمكنها من
تحرير كافه اراضيها
تقر اوكرانيا بان المعارك على الجبهات
تزداد صعوبه كل يوم وتكثف في موازاتها
حملتها الدبلوماسيه لاقناع حلفائها بان
امدادها بالاسلحه المتطوره لا يورطهم في
حرب عالميه ثالثه كاترين حنه الجزيره كييف
وينضم الينا الان من بيروت لويس ميغيل
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن اكياس
ايفانا كليمبوش رئيسه لجنه التكامل
الاوروبيه في البرلمان الاوكراني ونائبه
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني سابقا اهلا بضيفين
نبدا من بيروت والسيد بيونو هل هل الوقت
فعلا مناسب لبحث موضوع
بدء انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
مساء الخير شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه
اعتقد انه نعم الاجابه هي نعم هناك كان
هناك طلب واضح من قبل سلطات الاوكرانيه
للانضمام بالاتحاد الاوروبي هذه الظروف
فعلا استثنائيه يعني اول مره في تاريخ
الاتحاد هناك دوله اسلحه دوله مرشح رسميا
للنضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي وهي تتعرض بنفس
الوقت لاي عضوان عسكريه دوله اخرى ولكن مع
ذلك العلاقات المتينه بين الاتحاد
واوكرانيا تعود الى عقود يعني نتحدث عن
هذه المفاوضات حول التجاره واتفاقيات
تجاريه بين الطرفين في التسعينات مثلا
يعني ليست جديد من هذا الامور ولكن طبعا
هناك شروط لهذا الانضمام ونحن نرحب
بالاصلاحات الجاريه في اوكرانيا
وهذا القمه هذا الاجتماعات اللي صارت
امبارح لاول مره على فكره في يعني طلعت
اللي فيه حاله حرب
هذه يعني هذا افضل دليل لعزم اوروبا
لمواصله هذا الدعم المباشر المستمر
لاوكرانيا للشعب الاوكراني خلال هذه
الفتره صعبه لتمر بها اوكرانيا طبعا نحن
وسائط وسنقدم كل ما لدينا من ادواتنا
لاوكرانيا لاستعمال هذه العمليه وقت ممكن
اشرت الى كل كلمه شروط وعاده هذه الشروط
للانضمام تطول وهناك دول تعرفها بالتاكيد
تنتظر الان منذ سنوات هل سيكون هذا هو
مصير اوكرانيا ايضا
طبعا الشروط موجوده بالفعل يعني السلطه
الاوكرانيه تدرك ذلك وتعمل على استجمام
الاصلاحات واجراء هذه الازاحه اللازمه
مرتبطه بما يسمى الاوبينيون او التقرير
الساده العام المفضل الاوروبيه قبل شهور
اللي هي تتعلق بالساحات يعني مثلا تعديل
المحكمه القانون المتعلق الدستوريه يعني
تعين القضاء مكافحه الفساد وما الى ذلك
هناك سلاحات معروفه وبنفس الوقت يعني من
الرائعه ان نكون يعني ان نشحد بالفعل ان
هناك دوله
عسكريه عليها وفي نفس الوقت تستطيع اجداح
هذا الاجراءات وهذا الاصلاحات بشكل يعني
ناجح
كبير جدا يعني نحن يعني نشد قدره اوكرانيا
بهذا المجال بالفعل ومره اخرى اعتقد انه
هناك اجماع في مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي حول
ضروره مواصله هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا
مفاوضات حول انضمامها للاتحاد
اهلا وسهلا بك هل لديك
ثقه في ان هذا المسار سيتوج فعلا في
القريب بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
انا ليس لدي اي توقع اخر ان اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي انا ايضا
اعتقد ان اوكرانيا ستصبح ايضا عضوا في
النيتو وهذا موقف فريد من نوعه اننا في
هذه الحرب الصعبه الاصعب التي راتها
القاره الاوروبيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه نحن نخوض في هذه الحرب لكننا نركز
في نفس الوقت على اجراء تحول ايجابي في
البلد بالتالي هذه امر في غايه الاهميه
وهو يعكس الرغبه والحلم رغبه الشعب
الاوكراني ووجود مثل هذه الفرصه التاريخيه
في ان نكون دوله مرشحه نحن نعمل بجهد من
اجل تحقيق هذا الهدف والانتقال الى الخطوه
الثانيه الثانيه في مساله مفاوضات العضويه
مثل ما اشار السيد بيونو
لاول مره دوله في حاله حرب تطلب الانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الا يخيفكم ذلك
بمعنى ان الاتحاد سيكون متحفظا نوعا ما
لانه يرث عبئا ثقيلا على الصعيد الاقتصادي
واعاده الاعمار وغير ذلك
اعتقد بدايه
النقطه الاهم اننا نقدر موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي اننا نحارب اليوم
دفاعا عن القيم
حقوق الانسان والمبادئ الديمقراطيه وهي
العمود الفقري للاتحاد الاوروبي بالتالي
لدينا الكثير من النقاط التي مشتركه وايضا
نرى مستقبلنا سويه
بالتالي من المفهوم انه سيكون هنالك ربما
عواقب جديه بعد هذه الحرب لان روسيا تحاول
ان تمحين عن خارطه العالم وتحاول ان تدمر
كل شيء يمر في طريقها لكن هذا لا يعني ان
هذا قد يمثل عبء ان اعتقد ان من المهم انه
يمثل ان يمثلوا فرصه مهمه للجميع من اجل
اعاده انعاش ما نؤمن به والنظمنه ان
الديكتاتوريات
والحكام المستبدين لا يقومون بمهاجمه
بلداننا وان لا تسود قوتهم على قوه
القانون وعلى حق الانسان بالعيش سيد بيونو
الوضع الاستثنائي لاوكرانيا في طلب
الانضمام هل يشجع الاتحاد الاوروبي على
التعجيل في الاجراءات وربما حتى التخفيف
من بعض الشروط
اعتقد انه العكس هو صحيح نحن راينا هذا
العزم ويعني هذا الاراده الحقيقيه لذا ليس
فقط السلطات الاوكرانيه وانما الشعب
الاوكراني عموما باتجاه هذه العمليه عمليه
انضمامه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ويعني
بخطوات سريعه وافعاله وملموسه جدا خلال
شهور الماضيه مرتبطه بهذه العمليه
فاعتقد انه هناك من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
من قبل اوكرانيا الرقبه مشتركه للمزيد من
التعاون حول يعني هذا الامر لاجراء هذه
لصاحات اللازمه وبعد المفاوضات ولكن طبعا
نتحدث عن 35 بندا حول يعني قابل الانضمام
الرسمي للاتح ولكن يعني اريد النشيد الى
نقطه اساسيه اللي هي طبعا انه نحن نمر
بفتره استثماريه جدا في القاره الروبيه
مره اخرى التضامن الروبي بالتجاره
الاوكراني غير موجود فقط على مستوى ق ولكن
ايضا على الشعر الفراغ المستوى شارع
الاوروبيه كذلك شكرا جزيلا لك السيد
شكرا لك سيده ايفانا
وزير العدله الامريكي اول عمليه نقل
للوصول الروسيه المصادره لاستخدامها لدعم
اوكرانيا عبر وزاره الخارجيه واكد جراند
لدى استقباله المدعي العام الاوكراني
ان المدعين العامين الامريكيين
والاوكرانيين يعملون معا في التحقيقات
بشان الحرب الروسيه مضيفا انه يجري العمل
على تحديد الافراد الذين نفذوا الهجمات
على المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
واولئك الذين امروا بها من جهاته قال
المدعي العام الاوكرانيه اوندري كوستين
انه تم اليوم التصديق على نقل اصول مصادره
بقيمه خمسه ملايين الف دولار الى وزاره
الخارجيه لصالح اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا
ومعنا من موسكو اندريه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد كيف يمكن ان
تستقبل الخطوه من هذا القبيل في موسكو
يعني طبعا روسيا لا تهتم بذلك بسبب من
جديد نحن نستخدم بالمعايير المزدوجه حاليا
هناك الاتهامات شهر روسيا بانها تقوم
بشرائم الحرب بين الافراد في روسيا يقومون
باجرام الحرب ولكن على ما يبدو الكل ناصيه
ان خلال ثمانيه سنوات الماضي اوكرانيا
كانت تقصف مدينه دانيت وكذلك قطعت شبه
الجزيره القرم عن مياه الشرب وليس هذه هذه
هي الجرائم القبل السلطات الفكيه
وبالمناسبه انا ذاكر ان اوكرانيا تعتبر كل
من
وكذلك جزء من اراضيها فلذلك من هذه وجهه
النظر اوكرانيا تقوم باجرام الحرب ضد
شعبها ولكن لا احد يهتم بذلك ولا احد يجري
تحقيقا حول هذا الموضوع فلذلك طبعا كما
قلت نحن نستخدم بالمعايير المزدوج الان
المبالغ لا تعتبر كبيره جدا خمس ملايين
دولار و 400 الف دولار ولكن هل تعتقد بان
هناك خشيه انه اذا استمر هذا التمشي فقد
تصبح المبالغ اكبر واكبر في الفتره
المقبله
بتابعنا الحال سنرى هذه المبالغ ازدياد في
هذه المبالغ ولكن كما قلت طبعا كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان تهتم بهذه التحقيقات بهذه
بهذه الاشياء عندما كما قلت هي
مرتبطه او مبنيه على معايير المزدوجه
فبتعبيل الحل انا اعتقد ان لن تكون هناك
اي جدوى في مصلحته الاجارات من قبل كل من
اوكرانيا او غيرها من الدول لذلك في نهايه
المطاف
السيناريوهات ستكون ستتطور على ساحل
القتال هو مبني على تطورات الاحداث على
ساحه القتال
سيتم اتخاذ القرار حول يعني مصيره ومصير
اخر حول يعني
حل هذه الازمه بشكلها وبشكل
من الاصول الروسيه المصادره هل هناك تقدير
تقريبا
لحجم هذه الاصول الروسيه المصادره
هذا السؤال جيد جدا يمكننا ان نقول ان
طبعا
السلطات الغربيه قد اعتقلت كثير مليارات
من الاصول الروسيه فانا في المطار سيتم
سحب جزء من هذه
المبالغ ولكن كما قلت طبعا هذا النهب نهب
من الثروات الروسيه يعني انا اعتقد ان كل
دوله اوكي كثير من الدول العربيه استخدمت
بذلك في
السابق لا يوجد شيء جديد في ذلك ولكن
سياسيا سياسيا لن يكون هناك اي تاثير على
مصير العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا لا ضروسي اهداف معينه وروسيا
ستحاول ان تحقق تلك الاهداف بغض النظر عن
ايه الخطوات في مجال الاقتصادي انسانيه
سياسي او غيرها من المجله شكرا جزيلا لك
سيدي
وكان وزير العمل الروسي يجيب على سؤالي
فقد قدر قبل شهور مبالغ بلاده التي جمدتها
الدول الغربيه قدرها بحوالي نصف احتياطات
روسيا من الذهب والعملات الاجنبيه اي
حوالي 300 مليار دولار من جهاتها افادت
وحده العمل التابعه للحلفاء الغربيين
المسؤولين عن تعقب الاصول العائده للنخب
الروسيه بان الحلفاء الغربيين جمدوا 30
مليار دولار من الاصول المملوكه للاثرياء
او النخب وحاول 300 مليار دولار للبنك
المركزي الروسي مشيره الى انه تم الحجز
على عقارات مملوكه او يسيطر عليها رعايه
روس فرضت عليهم عقوبات ومنذ انطلاع الحرب
اعلنت بريطانيا تجميد اصول تزيد قيمتها عن
عشرين مليار و500 مليون دولار مملوكه
للاوليجارش وافراد اخرين وشركات
[موسيقى]
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي ان الاتحاد بات اكثر تصميما على
انقاذ البلاد مما وصفه بالعبث وعلى طرح
مبادرته التي اقلقت السلطه حسب تعبير كلام
الطبوب هذا جاء في مؤتمر الصحفي بعد
اجتماع طارئ للهيئه الاداريه للاتحاد الذي
اشار الى ان حق الاضراب تحول الى منطلق
لضرب العمل النقابي حسب وصفه وقد اكد
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد سامي الطاهري تمسك
الاتحاد بالحوار كوسيله للخروج من الازمه
الراهنه في البلاد
نجدد تمسكنا بالحوار سبيلا وحيدا للخروج
من الازمه المعقده التي تمر بها البلاد
ونذكر بموقف الاتحاد حول طبيعه الحوار
واهدافه والياته ومكوناته الذي ضمن في
بيانات الهيئه الاداريه الوطنيه المتعاقبه
ومنها الهيئه الاداريه الوطنيه التي
انعقدت يوم 23 مايو 2022
لقد دانت الهيئه الاداريه للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل بشده ما وصفته بخطاب
التحريض والتخوين والتجيش من قبل الرئيس
قيس سعيد بحق الاتحاد وعددا من مكونات
المجتمع التونسي ودعت الهيئه النقابيين
التونسيين للدفاع عن اتحاد الشغل
اشدد على ان قراراتنا مستقله
لا تنبع الا من اراده هياكلنا وقواعدنا
وندعو هياكلنا نقابيه الى التعبئه ونحث
النقبيات والنقابيين الى التجند ورص
الصفوف وتمتين الوحده كما نطالبهم كل من
موقعه بمواجهه الحملات الاعلاميه المضاده
للعمل النقبي والمشككه في جدواه والمشوهه
للاتحاد
وكلل منه العامل للاتحاد نور الدين طبوبي
قد اتهم الرئيس قيس سعيد بدعوه الشعب من
خلال خطابه السياسي الى الاقتتال
يدعو
بطريقه مباشر غير مباشره او غير مباشره
الى الشعب التونسي الى الاقتتال والتحارب
وهو هذا امر خطير جدا ويؤلف في الناس على
بعضها رئيس الجمهوريه انه اليوم باشيه
يسحب الانظار على النتائج الهزيله والحضور
معناها الضئيل والضعيف
معناها الانتخابات في الدور الاول والثاني
الانظار على الفشل الذريع في كل الخيارات
الاقتصاديه
وتداعيات اللي وصل لها المجتمع التونسي هو
انه
ده باش يقول انه الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل اليوم دورك
اما الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد فقال انه
لابد من تطهير البلاد
ومحاسبه من عبث بكل مقدراتها حسب تعبيره
وخلال تدشينه الطريقه السريعه الرابط بين
جابس وراس جدير علق سعيد على اضراب نقابه
الطرق السريعه فقال ان هذه الطرق ليست
ملكا خاصا لتغلق وان القانون يجب ان يطبق
على الجميع
معنى من تونس العاصمه طارق السعيد الصحفي
بجريده الشعب التابعه للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ومن مدينه سوسه شرق ساحل
تونس قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث في
القانون اهلا بضيفين نبدا بالسيد الصياح
هل تعتقد بان الرئيس قيس سعيد فتح على
نفسه جبهه ليس من السهل
تحمل تداعياتها
مساء الخير شكرا لك لضيفك الرئيس قيس سعيد
عديد المرات الى الحوارات في سنه 2020 ما
سمي بحوار رؤساء الحكومات وانت ترسل منه
الاتحاد والحوار الثاني حوار الفعل ورد
الفعل والذي تنصل منه ايضا مره ثانيه
الاتحاد والحوار الثالث حوار ما سمي
بالاستشاره الالكترونيه
وتنصل منه الاتحاد والان الاتحاد يتقدم
الى رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد بمبادره جديد
ولدت ميده وعرجه باعتبار ان الاليات
الاربعه لتقييم اي حوار سياسي في السياسه
هو التفاهم ثم اليه التوافق ثم الحصول على
نتائج كل هذه المعايير مفقوده الان
باعتبار ان الخطاب انزلق الى مربع الخطاب
والخطاب المعادي وانزلق الى مربع الاتهام
والتكوين من كل جهه وهذا الامر بطبيعته لن
يؤدي الا الى تعكير الامور وص فكيف نتحدث
عن حوار وقد بدل الاتحاد في شخص السيد
الامين العام نور الدين الطبوبي بتوجيه
توام الاقتتال لرئيس الدوله الان نحن في
وضع خطير وفي منزلق خطير ويجب على كل
الاطراف ان تكون في حاله وعي سياسي تام
اما ان ننخرط في اصلاح تام للبلاد واما
انخرطت في تدمير كامل الاقتصاد والبلاد
ثانيا اريد ان اعرج على نقطه هامه وهامه
جدا الاتحاد عديد المرات يعني يطالب رئيس
الدوله بالاصلاح ما الذي يفعله الاتحاد في
السنوات الفارطه لاصلاح المنظومه ولاصلاح
المنوال التنموي
وايقاف نزيف القروض التي تسلط على تونس
وبلغت 110 الف مليار وعزم ميزان تجاري
تضخم منذ حكومه السيد بلغ 8% لماذا لم
نتحدث عن هذا الامر من قبل ثم
بعد اذنك يعني قد تكون هذه قد تكون هذه
اسئله مشروعه توجه للاتحاد ولكن الاتحاد
في المقابل وهنا اسال السيد
توجه اليه بعض الانتقادات من قبيل انه
الاتحاد ساند الانقلاب وهو الان يدفع
فاتوره هذه المسانده وانه تساهل في خطوات
سعيه طوال اكثر من عام ونصف الى ان وصلت
الضربه الى راسه الان كيف يرد على من يقول
هذا الكلام
مساء الخير تحيه لك ولضيفك الكريم ولكافه
المشاهدين في اعتقادي ان هذا الكلام مردود
عليه بطبيعه الحال من زاويه نظر اولا انه
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل لم يكن
في السلطه ولم يشارك في اي سلطه وهو قوه
اقتراح وقوه تقديم مبادرات وهو من هذا
المنطلق
اقام وبنى
تصورا كاملا ومد بهير رئاسه الحكومه في
اطار التفاعل في اطار ما يسمى
بالمقترح هي الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
لديه بدائله ولديه تصوراته اليوم في تونس
المشكله مشكله خيارات دون يعني
زيف او دون مداراه نحن نعيش مرحله
اختلافات جوهريه في الخيارات هذه الخيارات
التي يطرحها الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
من حيث الشعارات التقطت في المرحله الاولى
مع ما طرحه الرئيس قيس سعيد عندما اعلن
السير نحو الحكم محلي وتعزيز من اجل دعم
الديمقراطيه ومن اجل كل تلك الشعارات التي
رفعها اصبحت
الى هذا انا اشير الى ان قيس سعيد عندما
اتخذ في 25 جويليه ما وصف بانه انقلاب على
الدستور الاتحاد رحب وفي مرحله بعدها
حرض حتى الرئيس على حل البرلمان لكنه لم
يكن يتخيل ان الامور ستصل الى هذا المنحى
كانه اراد ان يتخلص من بعض الخصوم ولكن
الدائره دارت عليه الان هذا هو سؤالي
طيب ساجيب حول هذه النقطه اولا الاتحاد
العام
بتاريخ الى 25 جوي الذي اختار نفس الموقف
على اعتبار ان الجميع يتذكر ان كنا امام
ازمه سياسيه خانقه
لا تمكن ان تحل ابره الا عبر المرور بقوه
وكان البرلمان يعد العده لعزل الرئيس وكان
الرئيس يعد العده لحل البرلمان هذا صراع
سياسي سياسي بطبيعه الحال عندما تمكن
الرئيس من حل هذا الاشكال والمرور الى
مرحله اخرى دعا الاتحاد الى البناء على
هذه الخطوه واعتبارها حاله انفراد سياسي
يمكن ان نبني عليه ووضع ثلاث محاذير
المحذير الاول هو عدم التشفي وعدم ظلم
الناس المحضر الثاني احترام شروط
ديمقراطيه والمعيار الثالث وهذا هو اللي
كان المهم هو الحوار الوطني من اجل مخرج
مشترك
على فكره الحوار على ذكر الحوار الوطني
اسال الان السيد قيصر السياح هل هل
المبادره التي يعتزم تقديمها الاتحاد
سيتفاعل معها الرئيس في ضوء هذا الشحن
المتبادل بين الطرفين
لا اعتقد ذلك مطلقا وقلت عديد المرات حتى
لم ينبر الجزيره قلت ان الرئيس منذ
اسبوعين لم يتحول رئيس في ذهنه الان وهذا
قلت حتى سابقا قلت على مسؤوليه الخاص
الرئيس في ذهنه الان ان هناك اطراف سياسيه
تريد الرجوع الى المربع الاول لو سمي
بمربع الحوار الوطني الحائز على جائزه
نوبل للسلام لاعاده التموقع ليس هناك عمل
منظماتي الرئيس يطالب بحوار وحيد وهو حوار
لا مقايضه يرفض الحوار الذي يكون تحت اليد
الغليظه او حوار كسر العظام عندما انتقلنا
في لحظات بين الامس الى هذا التصعيد
الخطير فالرئيس بطبيعه الحال يسير في مسار
خريطه الطريق الاصليه والصحيحه لاصلاح
البلاد وارجاع هيبه الدوله وتطبيق القانون
والقانون فوق الحق النقابي عندما يتجاوز
الحدود والحق النقابي مضمون بالماده من
العهد دوله حقوق الانسان شكرا لك قيصر
الصياح من
شكرا لك طارق السعيدي من تونس
[موسيقى]
فرنسيس شباب الفاتيكان قادت جنوب السودان
الى نبذ العنف الذي تشهده البلاد منذ سبع
سنوات ومنح شعب جنوب السودان حياه افضل كي
ينعم هذا البلد الفتي بالسلامه وفي كلمه
له في مستهل زياره تاريخيه الى هذا البلد
اعتبر الباب ان الوقت قد حان لاظهار
الالتزام بالسلام ونبذ الاقتتال داعيا
المجتمع الدولي الى مواصله دعم جنوب
السودان الاحدث استقلالا في افريقيا زياره
البابا تزامنت مع مزيدا من اعمال العنف
التي اودت بحياه نحو 20 شخصا اليوم
الان
ننتقل الى واشنطن وهذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
نحن واثقون من انه منطادو مراقبه وعندما
فعلنا ذلك
تصرفت الولايات المتحده من اجل حمايه
معلوماتها الحساسه
وتواصلنا مع
الصينيين وكثير من فرق عملنا تواصلت مع
الجهات المعنيه والى
مع الكونجرس في الولايات المتحده
وتوصلنا الى ان ظروف غير مناسبه لزياره
بناءها في مثل هذا الوقت
وقد اوضحت لنظير الى ان وجود هذا المنطاد
انتهاك لسياده بلدنا وهذا عمل غير مسؤول
وخاصه
قبيله زياره الى الصين
وقلت للمدير وانج ان المتحده تظل
ملتزمه بالحوار الدبلوماسي مع بيجين عندما
تصبح الظروف ومناسبه لذلك
وفي الاثناء القنوات موجوده في للحديث عن
هذا الحادث وهذا بالضبط لماذا نحتاج الى
نور نترك قنوات التواصل
مفتوحه حتى نتجنب الحسابات الخاطئه ملاحظه
اخيره ومهمه العالم يتوقع من البلدين ان
نتصرف ان نتعامل مع علاقاتنا بشكل مسؤول
وهناك تحديات تؤثر في شعبينا وشعوب العالم
علينا ان نعمل معا للمتحده سوف تستمر في
العمل بطريقه مسؤوله
وننتظر من شريكنا او نظيرنا الصيني
ان يتصرف كذلك نحن اذا وقعنا
فكره تتفاهم حول العلوم والتكنولوجيا
ونحن نتعاون منذ ثلاثه عقود في مجالات
تتغير المناخ
لتطوير البحث في الشرائح
الالكترونيه وكذلك دعونا في مجال العلمي
فيما يتعلق
باللقاحات
لصناعه
لقاحات فاعله لكوفيد من اجل منطقه
الاسيويه ونحن تناقشنا حول تعزيز هذه
العلاقات في مجال الفضاء ايضا
والتكنولوجيا العضويه والصناعه الذكاء
الاصطناعي
اذا العلوم هي احد اهم المجالات التي نعمل
ونتعاون فيها من اجل شعبينا ونسعى الى
تدريب
اذا القيام بمناظره عسكريه معا وكما قال
الرئيس
اننا نريد الازدهار والسلامه في المنطقه
وهناك الاستراتيجيه الجديده لكوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان
ونحن نعيد تاكيد التزامنا
بالتعاون لحمايه
مصالحنا ونستخدم
امكانات الولايات المتحده بما فيها
النوويه
والوزير وزير الدفاع
بنظيره الكوري الجنوبي لتعزيز التعاون في
مجال تبادل المعلومات حول التهديد النووي
لكوريا الشماليه
وقد ناقشنا
فرص الدفاع عن الامن والسلام في مضيق
تايوان
للتعامل مع التهديدات الامنيه
معن
وقد قمنا بمناورات في الخريف الماضي
ونحن نساعد ايضا دول منطقه الهند
والباسيفيكي لتعمل معا ونحن نعمل مع دول
اخرى
لدعم التنميه الاقتصاديه وخاصه في اطار
العمل منطقه بلدان المنطقه
وشركتنا تمتد خارج منطقه الباسيفيكي
وبلدان وقف معا لفرض عقوبات على روسيا
بمنعها من
الاستمرار في عدوانها على اوكرانيا
ونحن هنا نعمل مع
تحالف
كبير وفيه كوريا واليابان
اذا مواصله لهذا الموضوع الذي تحدث فيه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي هذا التوتر بين
الصين والولايات المتحده فقد شكل التجسس
احد مظاهر التنافس بين جانبين هذا التجسس
لم يكن عسكريا فحسب بل ينسحبوا على مجالات
وقطاعات كبيره وعديده منها مثلا سعي الصين
الحصول على معلومات تقنيه تمكنها من تعزيز
اقتصادها وحضورها في النظام الجيول
السياسي العالمي بينما تسع واشنطن لمنع
ظهور منافسين لنفوذها العالمي تنتهي موا
واشنطن بجين بسرقه الاصول الفكريه للشركات
الامريكيه والغربيه او محاوله سرقه على
الاقل لتسريع تقدمها الصناعي والتكنولوجي
والهيمنه على ساعات الكبرى تشير تقارير
صحفيه امريكيه الى ان الصين تتجسس على
الشركات شركات الاسلحه في شركات في كل
مكان وهذا يشمل شركات الاسلحه والطيران
يشمل كذلك الذكاء الاصطناعي وحتى صناعه
الادويه بينما تنفي الصين وتقول ان واشنطن
تسعى لتشويه سمعتها مجالاتها اهتمام الصين
تشمل ايضا تقنيه النانو الهندسيه الهندسه
والتكنولوجيا التي تدرس الماده بابعاد
متناهيه الصغر وتستخدم في مجالات السيارات
والطب والنسيج وغيرها ويتهم الامريكيون
الصين كذلك بالتجسس على قواعد البيانات
وتطبيقات التصريحات الامنيه والسجلات
الطيران وسجلات التامين الطبي وغيرها
لاستغلال الثغرات للحصول على المعلومات
في المقابل تسعى واشنطن الى عرقله التي
تقدم الصين في مجال صناعه اشباه الموصلات
التي تدخل في صناعه الاسلحه والهواتف
الذكيه وترى ان استخدام الصين لهذه
التقنيه يشكل خطرا على امنها القومي رغم
توقيعها اتفاقيه عام 2015 والتي تقضي
بالامتناع عن عمليات السرقه السيبرانيه
للملكيه الفكريه فان حرب التجسس مستمره
بين الجانبين ففي عام 2016 اتهمت واشنطن
الصينيين بتنفيذ هجمات عده لسرقه معلومات
حكوميه وخلال العام الماضي اتهم وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه الصين
بتجسس واسع النطاق على الاف اجهزه
الكمبيوتر التابعه المؤسسات الحكوميه
ووجهت انذاك اتهامات لثلاثه ضباط من وزاره
امن الدوله الصينيه
وفي نوفمبر الماضي حكمت محكمه امريكيه
بالسجن 20 عاما على الصيني زو يانجون
بتهمه التخطيط لسرقه اسرار صناعيه مثل
تصميمات محركات توربينيه تعمل بالغاز
والبخار شركه هواوي الصينيه المشغله لشبكه
الجيل الخامس واجهت عقوبات في عهد ترامب
بدعوى ان عملها يشكل خطرا على الامن
القوميه الامريكي وهي تواجه ضغوطا واسعه
ومنعا من الحصول على التقنيات الامريكيه
اتهام مماثل وجهات اداره ترامب لتطبيق تيك
توك رغم تاكيد الشركه المالكه له انه منصه
عالميه ليس وليس منتجا صينيا انضم الينا
من اوكسفورد جوليو بوليسي وهو استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه المختص بالشؤون الاسيويه
في جامعه اوكسفورد اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
بوليسي
ما مدى خطوره هذه الجوله الجديده من
الاتهامات بين واشنطن
هي
بدرجه كافيه من الجديه بحيث جعلت وزير
الخارجيه بنكين وهو يقوم بتاجيل زياره
دبلوماسيه في غايه الاهميه
زياره من العاصمه واشنطن الى
بيجين ليس فقط
للقائي نظيره باللقاء رئيس الصيني نفسه
بالتالي
الموضوع جدي ومن الواضح ان الجانب الصيني
يعترف ان الموضوع جدي عن طريق
اطلاقي بيان رسمي اعبر عبر فيه الصيني
الصين عن اسفها عن جنوحي هذا
المنطاد ودخوله الاجواء الامريكيه نتيجه
لقوه كبرى قد يكون صحيحا ان الصين قد
حاولت التجسس عن
المنطقه الحساسه عن طريق استخدامي انظمه
الرادارات بالتالي فان تاسيس
النشاطات الصينيه في الغرب لا يجعل من
السهل ايجاد حل لهذه الازمه وهل تعتقد ان
فعلا هذه الطريقه طريقه منطاد اسلوب معتمد
في التجسس بين البلدين هامين مثل الصين
والولايات المتحده
لقد تم تقليديا كان هو جزء من عده ادوات
تستخدم للتجسس لكنه اداه ربما منخفضه
التكنولوجيه في عهد اذا مقرناها
برادارات او الستلايتات او الاقمار
الصناعيه بالتالي من المحيري جدا ان نرى
هذا المنطاد الذي قد يكون او لا يكون
السيطره عليه ونرى جنوحه بهذه الطريقه وقد
ربما ادى الى انفجار هذه او تاجييل هذه
الزياره المجدوله لمده طويله لان الصين
ارادت ان ربما ان تضع الاساس من اجل انعاش
العلاقه بين الصين والولايات المتحده خاصه
في ظل التاريخ ربما غير السار لهذه
العلاقه رغم
تاجيل زياره بلانكن هل يمكن ان تسوء
العلاقات اكثر من ذلك
كلا اعتقد ان ما سيحدث ان الولايات
المتحده ستستفيد من هذه الازمه من اجل
الحصول على تنازلات اكثر من الصين من
الواضح من البيان الصيني ان جانب الصينيه
سفو لمثل هذا الحادث بالتالي من المحتمل
جدا ان الولايات المتحده سيكون لها اليد
الاعلى كما كان هو الحال ربما من اجل
الحصول على تنازلات على طاوله الدبلوماسيه
بالتالي انا
ربما منفتح للاحتمالات المشكله هو كيف ان
التسيس من كلا البلدين
ربما سيتوقع من الرئيس الصيني ومن الرئيس
الامريكي ان يكون اكثر مواجهه
لبعضهم البعض مع ذلك تعتقد بان من مصلحه
الصين ومن مصلحه الولايات المتحده ان يطوق
سريعا هذا الخلاف
نعم نعم اعتقد ذلك انا اقرا
هنالك رغبه من الاداره بايدن ان يتم تفادي
اسقاط هذا المنطاد وايضا كان هنالك حديث
عن النيه الجيده او ما يعكس
نيه جيده عن ما اعتقد انه حقا هو حادث
ربما خرج عن السيطره هل تعتقد ان على
الصين ان تقدم هي على الخطوه الاولى
لاعاده جسور الثقه نوعا ما مع الولايات
المتحده
هي قامت بذلك عن طريق البيان الذي اصدرت
حيث ان هنالك اعتراف حقيقي بان كان خطا من
جانب الصين ان يكون هنالك
ربما
جهاز يعود لها يستخدم لاغراض الارصاد
الجويه او لاغراض اخرى ان يخرج عن السيطره
ويدخل الاجواء الامريكيه لكنه مع ذلك هو
اعتراف من الصين انها لم ترغب بحدوث هذا
الامر ليس بهذه الطريقه وليس في هذا الوقت
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور جوليو بوليسي من
اكسفورد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص
بالشؤون الاسيويه في جماعه اوكسفورد وقد
حدثنا عن هذه الازمه بين الولايات المتحده
والصين في اعقاب دخول هذا المنطاد الذي
نراه الان على الشاشه والذي احدث هزه
كبيره في العلاقه
واشنطن تتهم الصين بانها تعمل على التجسس
عليها بينما الصين لا ترى الامر بهذا
الشكل وترى بان المساله ربما اخذت اكثر من
حجمها واهم تطور هو تاجيل او الغاز زياره
انطوني بلينكن التي كانت مقرره الى الصين
تاجيلها الى موعد لم يحدد بعد بسبب هذه
الازمه نهايه الحصاد شكرا على المتابعه
ننتقل بكم الان الى جوله منتصف الليل مع
مياده عبده وحسن جمهور